[ __ ] another eventful week in
Washington we're joined by Bob Cusack
editor-in-chief of the hill Bob good
morning good morning how significant is
the impact of this memo well I think
it's significant in that it raises some
questions but remember we've only seen
the Republican memo we haven't seen the
Democratic will we see the Democratic I
think we will because Republicans took
so much heat and not releasing at the
same time so this memo raises questions
and will the Democratic memo answer
those questions but it's just another
example of how the House Intelligence
Committee which used to be a very
bipartisan panel is really broken yeah
well that was my next question how does
the work of that committee continue
that's a good question I mean that
members are on both sides the aisle are
calling each other liars I mean they're
saying diametrically different things
about what's in this memo and the
veracity of it so I think it's very
difficult now the Senate Intelligence
Committee works very differently and
very bipartisan what's what are the most
significant this memo which which was
advertised as one thing has it delivered
on what it advertised well I think
everything in Washington is a little bit
overhyped and I think this one was a bit
overhyped at the same time it does raise
questions of of what they told the FISA
Court did they not give them the
information fully that this was paid for
by the Democratic National Committee
Hillary Clinton is that true there are
different accounts of whether that's
true right and well then there's a
question of whether that matters because
the memo does not seem to say that the
intelligence presented in dossier was
somehow compromised right there's a
question of sources partisanship and
what meaningful effect that actually has
on an investigation right out so I mean
I think the bottom line is the memo is
making the case that the FBI was unfair
and violated Carter pages rights now the
question is that is that accurate now
Peter King has said there should be
hearings on this I think that's a good
idea
let's say everything's let's get
everything out it all out and ask some
questions yeah I mean and the other
points made this that that that they
renewed this FISA order three times
correct right they have to go back to
the court and when they go back to the
court they can't present the exact same
case you know no they've got to present
more but basically make the case they're
making progress and remember that a lot
of this Democrats say is about rod
Rosenstein who there's been a lot of
speculation that Trump would fire the
because he was the one who set up the
special council and that would lead to
the end of robert muller so now others
like Republican leaders Paul Ryan said
no these are separate issues but rod
Rosen sign is mentioned in the memo this
is not the only skirmish between the
Trump administration and intelligence
agencies we know that the Justice
Department has an infest yeah it is
investigating the handling of Hillary
Clinton's email investigation what is
happening there and how measurably could
that affect an already polarized dynamic
I think that's one of the most
underrated stories it's about to happen
this inspector general report who this
report is being written by someone who's
respected on both sides of the aisle is
working under Bush and Obama been
critical of both and looking at the
Comey investigation now remember the FBI
chief Chris Rae has seen preliminary
findings of this report and that led to
DOJ official Andrew McCabe being pushed
out so something something bad about
mchavez in that report and maybe a lot
more maybe some critical criticism of
James Comey himself or interesting at
the same time we began this week with
the State of the Union address that some
people actually called unifying at the
time it doesn't at the end of the week
we don't exactly feel unified no Trump
to get a bump from it but at the same
time I don't think it moved the needle
and and some people say yeah some
Republicans and Democrats that actually
move them further away from a possible
deal on immigration so Trump got a bump
but at the same time I don't think he's
gonna get a lot of what he asked for Bob
what happens with the looming second
government shutdown this year yeah I
mean it's just basically a less than a
week away I don't think we could see if
shutdown next week the Democrats move
last time backfired and now I think
they'll punt again into March and now
remember then that's where we're dealing
with the dream or a deadline all bets
are off that I'm not sure what's gonna
happen then I don't know how this story
ends but I think next week they'll punt
again into March Congress very good at
punting punting seems to be the Super
Bowl weekend that's a good metaphor I
feel that they completely miss played
this last night well there are a lot of
conservative centrist Democrats who are
up for re-election in 2018 in the Senate
they got nervous they got very nervous
and they didn't want to be blamed so I
think that was the driving force and it
and Chuck Schumer I think learned from
that and is not gonna is gonna use a
different
I booked this time pop cusack thank you
as always thank you